I mostly get actioned.
If that makes sense.
Well, I get the crap beat
out of me a number of times.
Hi, I'm the hero
of Times Square.
I'm Lorraine.
- I'm knitting you a scarf soon.
I'm Langston.
And this is Earth's
Mightiest Show.
Where we talk
about all the most
Jessica Jones stuff in
the Marvel universe.
Yeah, because "Marvel's
Jessica Jones" Season
3 is almost here.
Add it to your
Netflix queue now,
so that you can stream all
13 episodes when they drop
on June 14, only on Netflix.
Plus there will be a lot more
about season three on the show
today.
So, gird your loins.
Oh, my lord.
Well, E3 was this week.
And boy, it's always a blast.
Oh my goodness lots of big
news about some upcoming Marvel
games, including MARVEL
ULTIMATE ALLIANCE 3:
The Black Order coming to
Nintendo Switch July 19.
LORRAINE CINK: And of course
there's Marvel's Avengers.
Very excited for this
game coming to Playstation
4, Xbox One, Stadia, and PC.
So if you guys are not yet
familiar with E3, get on it.
It's the Electronic
Entertainment Expo.
Yes, there are three Es in E3.
Yes.
It's a huge game convention in
LA where you can see new games,
play new games, see all types
of new stuff, technology,
it's a blast.
Yeah, our own Agent M
actually was there, a.k.a.
Ryan Penagos He was
on the scene and he
has all of the best of E3.
Oh I'm game.
Ha.
Let's watch.
Hey, y'all.
It is the most wonderful
time of the year, E3 in LA.
It's video game heaven.
I'm so excited.
It's been a wonderful time.
I saw so much, Marvel's
Avengers, MARVEL ULTIMATE
ALLIANCE 3: The Black Order.
There's so much fun stuff.
I gotta share with you my
favorite Marvel moments of E3.
Let's check them out.
We kicked off E3 2019 in
the biggest way possible
with Marvel's Avengers revealing
the game to the world, story,
characters, actors, settings,
some highs, some lows,
some tears, so much more.
And I'm super hyped for
the game and for E3 2019.
But I'm not the only one
hyped for Marvel's Avengers
this week.
[CHEERS]
If we were hyped for the
reveal, oh boy, oh boy,
we got so much more here
on the show floor at E3.
There is a giant
Marvel's Avengers booth.
And it is loaded with swag.
We've got lanyards and dossiers.
It's got costumes for
the five core Avengers
that you can check
out, see them in here.
But it all leads
to actually getting
to see about 30
minutes of gameplay
from Marvel's Avengers.
And it is mind blowing.
We went inside.
We saw a lot of cool stuff,
share with you what we can.
Oh, man.
But if you think this is it, no.
We got so much more to
see and do here at E3.
Let's check it out.
Nintendo's booth has been
swamped throughout E3 2019.
But we got in here
super early to get
exclusive access to
play MARVEL ULTIMATE
ALLIANCE 3: The Black Order.
Guys, it's so much fun.
Hell, yes, you guys,
you saw so much fun.
What an amazing E3.
Now remember, Marvel's Avengers
comes out May 15, 2020.
Make sure you preorder it
for ES4, Xbox, PC, or Stadia.
And of course, MARVEL
ULTIMATE ALLIANCE 3:
The Black Order comes out
July 19 on Nintendo Switch.
I can't wait.
And actually, I
got some more time.
I'm going to go play some games.
I'll see you soon.
Man, I'm so
jealous he got to go.
Looks so much fun.
I've got to get all--
I'm getting all those games.
Yeah, my thumbs are twitchy.
OK.
We are not here to play games
or least not to just play games.
That's we'll only
do some of that.
But let's talk about "Marvel's
Jessica Jones" Season Three.
Yeah, so much
happening. with Jessica.
Got her mom resurfacing,
Trish exploring
what it's like to have powers
of her own kind of sort,
and of course big drama
Jerry battling ALS.
Yeah, and that's
just where we're
going to pick up season three.
I mean season two was jam
packed and so emotional.
So I'm really excited
to see what happened.
Yes they were put through
the wringers of emotion
and trials and
tribulations, coming
out looking better and worse.
Who knows?
Because now season
three's coming.
But listen, I really
love they built out
that whole world that season.
It was really, really cool.
Well, you know, speaking of
being immersed in Jessica's
world, I got to tour the set.
Woo.
That's nice.
Let's take a look around.
Yeah.
Hey, Marvelites, I am
here on the set of "Marvel's
Jessica Jones" Season Three.
And I'm actually on a soundstage
in Brooklyn, New York.
A lot of people might not
realize that a lot of the sets
are actually built completely
originally here in a studio.
And I'm going to take you
inside for a little set tour.
Come on.
And now, I am on the set.
This is Jessica's elevator.
Of course, it's not an
elevator in real life
because there is a solid
floor underneath us.
But you might remember a
lot of dramatic moments
and awkward moments
shared in this elevator.
You want to go
to a movie sometime?
This is Malcolm's apartment.
[KNOCKING]
I don't think he's home.
He's probably entertaining
a lady friend.
But this is, of course,
Jessica Jones' assistant,
well, on again, off
again, on again,
off again, on again,
off, it's complicated.
But let's see if Jessica's home.
Here we are in Jessica
Jones's bedroom.
There have been a lot
of special moments
in this room and a lot
of drama, not only did
sparks fly between
Jessica and Luke Cage,
this is also the place where
Luke was brought when he had
a traumatic brain
injury and Claire
Temple had to save his life.
There are also of course
were sparks between her
and Oscar, her super.
But there was also
a beautiful moment
that she shared with her mom
where they laid right here
and slept, for the first
time together in 17 years.
And one of my favorite things
about being in this room
is, I definitely saw some
coconut body wash over there.
So now we all know what
Jessica Jones smells like.
Let's see what else I can find.
And here we are in
Jessica's kitchen.
OK, she's not necessarily
the best cook.
But she does have dishes.
And I mean, I do
sort of love this set
because it's all built
like a real cold water
tenement in the old days.
You've got exposed pipes
and all kinds of fun, funky
little details,
right down to a bunch
of leftover coffee in the sink.
I mean, relatable.
Let's see what else.
And here we are in
Jessica's living room.
And by living room, I mean this
is how she makes her living
for Alias Investigations.
This is where she does
all of her research,
whether it's finding out
where Kilgrave has been hiding
or what IGH is up to and how
she got her super powers.
And it looks like it's been
through some rough times
with these gouges.
But you know, when
she's looking for clues,
there's only one way you can
really string together a theory
and that's by putting
them all up on the board.
I guess sometimes that
can be frustrating,
if this big punch hole in this
board is to tell us anything.
But I'm going to be
looking for even more clues
about "Marvel's Jessica
Jones" Season Three.
You should check it out
streaming only on Netflix.
And for now, I'm just going
to kind of hang out with Jess.
I'm going to see if
she comes home later.
Bye, bye.
Whoa, I thought that
was an apartment building.
That's a set.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
It's a whole floor
of an apartment.
Jess lives there.
Malcolm lives there.
It's like it feels like home.
Is it home?
Did you move in?
I did.
I live there.
Yeah.
How much is the rent?
It's uh, I'm squatting.
It's fine.
Is there running water?
Yeah, well there is a lot
more to come this season,
including a new character
that will be a very
interesting foil for Jessica.
Yeah in fact, I caught up
with that mysterious character
played by the incredibly
fun Benjamin Walker
when I was hanging out
at Jessica's place.
Oh, dope, here it is.
I am hanging out here on the
set of "Marvel's Jessica Jones"
Season Three.
And look who I found.
It's Ben Walker.
Hello.
So what can you tell us about
your character, Erik Gelden.
Not a lot, but enough
to keep him interesting.
He is a blackmailer,
a gambler, a drinker.
He has moved to New
York from the South
for some family and
personal reasons.
And he's kind of found
himself in hot water, largely
because of his own behavior.
Right, so that's
on, that's on Erik.
Well, you meet Erik early
when he is drunk, in trouble,
in pain, and desperate.
That's perfect for Jessica.
That's like her whole thing.
Right, exactly.
It's kind of star
crossed lovers.
And he needs her help.
Right.
So that's how we meet Erik.
But he has a lot to offer.
And I think Jessica
quickly realizes that.
Now you get to of course
play opposite Krysten Ritter.
Sure.
What has it been like
working with Krysten?
She's great.
She's a pro on camera
and off camera.
She directed an episode.
So, that's been incredibly
positive, because you know,
this is my first kind
of long form television.
And to kind of have her
holding my hand through it
has been really great.
It's kind of like, (WHISPERING)
Ben, stand over there
and say it like this.
OK.
She's great.
And she whispers it
delicately like that?
Oh, no, no.
Krysten is very loud and
very straightforward.
Don't do it like that!
What can you tell us
about some of the action
that we might see
for this season,
because we know Jessica
can jump out of windows
and do some pretty cool stunts.
Well you get in on any action?
I mostly get actioned.
If that makes any sense.
Well, I get the crap beat
out of me a number of times.
Part of what's interesting about
Erik, and to this question,
is that he starts as kind
of a mess up, a screw up.
And through the course of it,
he learns to defend himself
and to fight for the right.
So in the beginning, he's kind
of getting his [BLEEP] whooped.
And by the end, he learns
that maybe he can flip that.
Well, I can't wait to see it.
I can't wait for
you guys to see it.
Thank you so much
for talking with us.
My pleasure.
Be sure to watch "Marvel's
Jessica Jones" Season Three,
streaming only on Netflix.
Benjamin, what a guy.
Can't wait to see how
his character interacts
with Jessica this season.
Me too.
Stream all episodes of the new
season of "Marvel's Jessica
Jones" tomorrow June 14, as
well as seasons one and two
now streaming only on Netflix.
Yeah, that's right.
I love Jessica so much.
I can't wait for
this new season.
Oh and tell us what you loved
most about "Jessica Jones"
and use that hashtag
EARTHSMIGHTIESTSHOW.
- See you next time.
- I'm Lorraine.
And I'm Langston.
And this is Marvel.
Your universe.